my basic thesis is if you if you hit all
the if you go around all the bases when
you're playing the game then you know
where all the bases are uh and that's
hard and uh and it takes a long time but
that's probably the best way to build a
career welcome to 20 minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Steve blue
Steve is president of and CEO of Miller
Ingenuity an international manufacturer
of high technology products that save
lives and preserve the environment Steve
has published five books that teach
senior leaders and CEOs how to increase
profit take market share and Destroy
competition he is an internationally
recognized expert on leading change in
business transformation Steve is a
highly acclaimed keynote speaker having
addressed audiences at Harvard Business
School the United Nations Carnegie Hall
industry week the world safe Summit CEO
clubs International and Medtronic
Corporation his leadership insights have
been featured in The Wall Street Journal
Fox News Fox Business Channel CNN CNBC
Forbes Fortune CEO World business week
and success magazines
Lou welcome to 28 minute leaders thank
you so much for being here how are you
thank you it's a pleasure to be here I'm
fine how are you
I am doing great and you're and you're
here all the way from Winona right all
the way there is a town called Winona
and I live in it
I love it well
um besides for the fact that you're the
president and CEO of Miller Ingenuity
and you are an author of multiple uh
multiple books you're talking to senior
leaders and CEOs on a variety of
subjects when it comes to leadership
business and performance
um and more even importantly you're also
very active with speaking to students
which we spoke about just before we
started and so a lot of different things
for me to pick to pick your your brain
on um but I want to start off very
quickly if you can just give me a little
bit about sort of your own Journey what
what's been guiding you and perhaps a
few of the key Milestones so then I want
to dive into a little bit about some of
the things that you talk to students
about
sure years ago and I fur I've been in
leadership positions now for industrial
leadership positions for a little more
than 45 years uh and so I tell people
when I consult and what I write and what
I uh when I give keynote speeches I tell
senior leaders you don't have a problem
that I haven't seen before and in fact
you don't have a problem that I haven't
already solved before because they're
early in my career Michael I I asked for
the toughest crumbiest out of the in the
little hole in the wall Place
assignments I could find because I I
knew nobody else was trying to solve
those problems and so if I could solve
them I'd I'd have a leg up on other
people in terms of promotions and so
forth and so and that that was very
useful uh and the other part about that
is I got to learn every part of the
organization from the bottom to the top
uh in any organization I know what goes
wrong in any part of it because I've
been there down in the trenches all the
way up through middle to ultimately
Senior Management so that's how I
learned sort of most of what I know
because I saw all the wrong ways people
were doing it and how to how to do it
correctly and so then I just started
writing about that and I just started
developing uh keynote speeches around
that and uh talking about you know what
works and what doesn't work and as it
turned out I sort of had the secret
recipe to Coke for some reason not I
couldn't say no other leaders in the
world have this down but a lot of them
just didn't see it and didn't understand
and I was able to offer it and I would
say in terms of key moments in my career
I I worked in a turnaround once for
seven years and uh that was the most
horrifying situation I've ever been in
it was also the most gratifying and it
was the most uh the situation where I
learned the most in that company Michael
we had to uh choose between paying
making payroll or keeping the lights
running that's how bad things were and
we were just bleeding anyway so uh from
that experience I learned Cassius King
if you don't have cash to run a business
you uh can survive and you have to make
sure that you can keep your eye on the
ball in terms of make your make your
numbers every week and if you make your
son some people will say oh we missed a
quarter so what so we'll make it up next
quarter I don't believe in that I
believe and if you make the numbers this
week you'll make the numbers next week
if you make the numbers next week you'll
make the numbers the following week and
uh that's one of the most important
lessons I ever learned and that's been
very helpful to me especially during the
pandemic when we came into the pandemic
a lot of companies went belly up because
they weren't washing their cash and
their balance sheets were loose and were
weak uh that wasn't the case with us we
uh we came out of the panda actually
pandemic stronger than we went in
going back to learning every part of the
organization experiencing every part of
it
and it feels like today me I I don't
know to compare it to
prior times but but it seems like today
um it's quite common not to perhaps skip
a few steps in when people enter
different organizations especially if
you look at software and high-tech yeah
it doesn't seem like everybody has you
know it like it traditionally goes
through from the entry level positions
all the way up you know there's
different things you can do in life that
will get you to intersect or sure the
industry at different positions what's
your take on that because that's I mean
it sounds like you've you're giving a
lot of credit to your own experiences
climbing the ladder yourself and
experiencing whereas somebody like
myself where I may be starting a new
company now at the age of 26 obviously
as a CEO I haven't experienced all these
different stages of a company
well if you talk about like and I know
you've done at least one of these a
startup if you talk about a startup you
know you know it's a brand new think
it's a brand new animal there are no
like stops and places to go and gain
experience in what the what what makes
the company
so that's a little different I would say
to people you know most people don't
have the opportunity uh or the desire to
work in every part of an organization as
they build a career it takes a long time
uh but there are some stops that you
have to have uh in in any company
especially a manufacturing organization
you have to understand sales for sure uh
and you have to understand the external
market and the and the marketing aspect
of the company and if you don't have
that I don't care what you have you
could know operations inside and out you
could know engineering inside now do you
understand the opposite environment all
the decisions the major decisions they
make revolving uh the future of the
company will be wrong
um and so when when people get promoted
in an organization they very seldom come
out of accounting they very seldom they
CFO very seldom gets the top job and I'm
not exercising I'm just saying stating
effect the hit engineer very seldom now
it could be different in a software
company in Silicon Valley but normally
the engineering guy doesn't get the top
job uh and so if you if they pick a guy
to get the top job it's almost always at
the sales guy because you have to have
that external uh commercial sense
running successful businesses
um from your
perspective your career what's been some
of the mo you mentioned a few a few of
these ideas like cash is King and Etc
what are really a few of the more
fundamental understandings that you have
when it comes to really building
something that creates value and doing
so sustainably as a leader so if we're
talking out to a group of people that
are aspiring to be you know Business
Leaders Executives CEOs et cetera what
what are things that we need to be
keeping in mind as we're building a
healthy organization whether it be
software
rails or or anything in the world
well as I mentioned already you have to
understand the external environment
first if you don't understand that uh
you're in the wrong job
and then this job of the the top person
is to connect the external environment
with the internal environment and uh
that's the tough
thing to do because uh now you're
talking about the human element if you
will because and that's a whole you know
numbers are easy formulas are easy
contracts are easy legal documents are
easy developments product new product
developments are easy people are hard
and uh if you don't get that people
aspect down right and connect that to
the outside environment uh then nothing
else you do is going to matter much
right
tell me a little bit more about your own
name your own path and what's been
guiding you throughout your own Journey
I've had an interesting path not pretty
non-conventional path I started off as a
factory supervisor that a large
industrial control company at the time
it was called Alan Bradley now it's I
believe it's owned by Rockwell
International
and so I started as Factory supervisor
and then I moved into as I looked around
I saw that the human resource people
seem to be calling all the shots
and so I moved into human resources and
sort of Built My Career for a number of
years up the ladder up the chain of
command and human resources in the same
company moved around a lot uh even from
one physical location another and then
you know after a while I got sick and
tired of telling the guys are running
the operations what they were doing
wrong uh particularly came to people
because whenever they had a people
problem they'd come to meet to solve it
well and and the thing of it is it's was
their people not my there was their
responsibility but they they just didn't
have a clue as to how to lead people and
after a while I got so tired of that
bailing these guys out that I decided I
was going to move into the line
organization yeah and so I took a job uh
with this turnaround actually at First
and she had a senior level human
resources job but with the understanding
of my boss that if I did a couple of
high level contract things that he'd
give me a shot at a line job and that's
how I moved into a a p l position in the
startup uh and then sort of my career
just sort of built from there so it was
pretty non-traditional Factory
supervisor Personnel into marketing and
sales and then eventually into General
management
transition
go ahead it's a tough way to build a
career in fact I wrote a piece once said
why you should want to do the tough way
to build a career and why you should
want to do that then
um and my basic thesis is if you if you
hit all the gore on all the bases when
you're playing the game then you know
where all the bases are uh and that's
hard and uh and it takes a long time but
that's probably the best way to build a
career
in my view
so now that you have I mean
you I can't I don't know many people who
have that who are able to see what
you're saying this is the way that
you've built your career the different
steps you took what perspective do you
feel like you have now over different
challenges and different opportunities
that somebody who didn't necessarily
have a tough career like you mentioned
didn't go through these steps may may be
experiencing well you know
um
you can't me I mean somebody in
the organization tries to spoof me into
thinking here's kind of what's going on
you you can't do it because I've been
there and done that and uh and
intuitively when when there's something
wrong in in an organization I know where
it is and I know where to look for it
and I know how to fix it a lot of people
don't they have to rely on people around
them and Below them who uh who may or
may not have the right perspective on on
the problem or the issue or the
opportunity because every word every
person in the organization and every
part of the organization has their own
biases and they have their own
perspectives and they have their own
interests and their own needs and they
don't always align with that of the
company sometimes they do you would hope
they do but they don't always and so I
can I can sniff that sort of thing out
uh from a mile away and that's very
helpful because I can cut to the chase
uh when a problem is developing or an
opportunity is developing much faster
than a lot of other people will on the
same side how can I work on my own how
can I work in my own way to uh to know
to identify and cut the
you know I mean because we're
so good at telling stories all day long
I want to be able to identify which ones
are real and which ones are just excuses
especially in the tech world I mean
we're full of stories all day long
well um you know uh the the term
emotional intelligence gets thrown
around a lot not so much now but he's
been in the days when the first book was
put out it just thrown around a lot you
have to have innate emotional
intelligence uh if you uh can stiff it
to in order to sniff this stuff out and
and I don't know that they teach that in
school I do know one thing uh but I've
always used an industrial psychologist
as a consultant and uh as an example the
industrial psychologist that I have I've
used them for 20 years he knows all the
senior leaders in my organization
because he's done a shrunk test on all
of them and he's interviewed them well
sometimes he said he rides shotgun with
us in all of our major initiatives and
so the more you got to know about these
guys they're all good guys don't don't
misunderstand me the more I can know
about these guys the more I can uh I can
tell when when something's afoot or
something isn't quite right other than
that I I you know read the book
emotional intelligence remember who
wrote it and uh and He suggests several
ways of developing better emotional
intelligence because it is an IQ that's
going to get you through an organization
it's gonna it's gonna be EQ
uh
you know I was writing that yourself
you're listening to somebody and you've
got that feeling on the back of your
neck and in your spine whatever you just
got that feeling something isn't right
about what this verse is telling me
always go with your gut on that and dig
in deeper
dig in deeper right I think that
another way to look at it is that some
people may draw conclusions based on
that feeling and then make assumptions
which may not always be the right thing
because that's necessarily that's a good
point because uh your first assumption
in conclusion is probably wrong
right you're doing what's wrong and then
look for the second solution okay when I
tell people all the time is and ask the
question behind the question
you know you ask a question to your Ops
guy why are shipments late well because
we didn't get our material in on time
well you don't stop there why didn't you
get the material in on time well because
Aspire is this why was the supplier that
there's always four or five levels deep
of questions you can answer before
you're ever going to get to the bottom
but most people
a lot of people except the first answer
and and draw conclusions so man you're
almost always wrong
100 100 and right before we started
recording you mentioned your ability uh
you're sitting with with some first year
students and you're able to to observe
some behaviors that that may be
indicative of of potential engagement or
success later on tell me a little bit
about the way that you're you know now
we're speaking to maybe the younger the
younger audience then then maybe
listening here perhaps even first-year
students at universities what what's
been your experience in your engagement
with students and following their
trajectories over the years you know I I
it's just been a thrill for me I've been
Associated uh with a couple of
universities in the area for I don't
know 10 or 15 years now so I've had the
opportunity to see like three
generations of young people come in as
freshmens and leave as seniors and so I
I've been fortunate enough to watch
their uh growth as I interacted with
them during all these times right but
when they get when they come in as
freshmen one one of the professors in
the University a good friend of mine
says they're barely out of they're just
out of high school they're just kids and
and you sort of have to in his view you
have to treat him like that you know
this first time they get freedom from
their parents and all that so you see
but there's a difference between the
people who will be successful by the
time they get out uh graduate and those
are the well and I see it in the first
year in the first class it's are they
interested and are they engaged and are
they listening or aren't they it's
really simple and uh over the years I've
sort of identified people without
telling anybody you know I don't want
the Peter Principle uh and what was it
the expectation expectancy Theory at
play here but I've been able to watch
them and say okay I tell my wife this
one's going to be winner this one will
just you know you'll never hear from
them again I've almost always been right
how so so what are these so some of
these more concrete indications that
because because it sounds like they're
they're they're shining on it on a
larger idea of Engagement to respect
um putting yourself on the court so what
are some of these things that if I were
to go back now to my first year you
would recommend me to do so that I can
so that I can be better engaged than
better put myself better for Success
yeah it's easier for an older person to
say this because when you're younger uh
you don't necessarily think this way but
when you when you get out of high school
and you get into your freshman year of
college you're Playing for Keeps now you
know you don't feel like you're Playing
for Keeps now but you're get you're
you're being washed you're being
evaluated everything you put out for
God's sake on social media will come
back to haunt you or help you in your
entire career and certainly in your life
and so you're playing you gotta keep in
mind that you're Playing for Keeps now
so act like you're Playing for Keeps pay
attention in class ask questions be
engage when you don't understand
something uh ask about it and don't just
take the easy classes that you know you
can get just easy quick credits for take
the tough classes those that will enrich
you and make you uh more valuable to a
potential employer later on
the final a thought or question where do
you get your joint excitement from it
sounds on one hand that you're very
serious about what you do on the other
hand it sounds like you you have a huge
regard and appreciation to your journey
and it sounds like you wouldn't have it
any other way where do you get your own
excitement and joy from
that's good quality I'll tell you a
quick story we got about two minutes
I'll tell you a quick story I uh started
a trade show company in Mexico I don't
know this is it's my first my first
entrepreneurial uh effort started a
trade show company uh there was there
was already a trade show going on in
Mexico but it was run by the U.S
Department of Commerce and and I knew I
could do better I didn't know anything
about the trade show business but except
having been to one and so I started this
company and I got a couple of Partners
one from Mexico another one from Chicago
and uh I put I had to pledge a hundred
thousand dollars of my own money to
guarantee the hotel rooms and the uh
exhibit hall space I didn't have a
hundred thousand dollars uh and the
night before the show was scheduled to
open up there was a huge massive storm
in the northeastern United States where
all my exhibitors were coming from and
so it was like the the whole thing was
going to come unraveled and I'd be on
the hook for 100 grand and it wasn't my
fault it was a snowstorm and anyway that
night I was absolutely scared to death
and as it turned out the show was a
phenomenal success and what I say to
people when I tell that story is if you
are scared shitless your your dream is
big enough and your effort isn't big
enough and you should you ought not to
be wasting your time on it
I love that
it's making a making it to my daily
quote I love that well then the other
thing is really quick then I had this is
where I say success begets success until
it doesn't so don't back on your success
for the next one they started a company
and Cuba right after that thinking I
could do absolutely no wrong I lost my
ass on the adventure
so one success doesn't mean another one
Steve thank you so much for the time and
for the insights I loved it and and I
really appreciate it continue making
huge positive impact on all those around
you and I look forward to sharing this
with everybody thank you very very much
my pleasure same to you thank you
[Music]